[Music]
on this Thursday night the forecast on
food costs after soaring prices in 2023
peanut butter has gone astronomically
out of sight a look at what most
Canadians can expect next year plus what
people in the north are forced to pay I
don't know how other families get to go
through that ottawa's plan to cap oil
and gas emissions what's promised and
who's not buying it there's no question
that if they continue on this path it
will end up with court serving up some
justice one unruly customer got a taste
of her own burrito in
court plus standing her ground if it is
offensive to you that is unfortunate the
flood of support for a global news
reporter who refused to be body
shamed global national with with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us some relief may be around the
corner for Canadians dealing with
sticker shock at the grocery store the
latest report on food prices forecasts
they will keep rising in 2024 but at a
slower Pace than this year a family of
four can expect to pay nearly $16,300
for food next year that's about $700
more than in 2023 the grocery industry
has been under intense pressure to
answer for record high profits as hadidi
petacha reports it could force chains to
entice Shoppers with more competitive
prices actually Canada's food price
report says the squeeze on food budgets
showed at checkouts from April to the
end of September people were spending
Less on food like a lot less a family of
four spent almost $700 less than
expected even with food price increases
which in Prince Edward Island and Quebec
jumped the most in the country by 6.7%
olive oil is unbelievable price all the
green stuff is uh very high prices
peanut butter has gone astronomically
out of sight pasta that used to be 9
cents for a 900 G bag is now $229 for an
800 G bag higher costs bringing more
people to this community food program
between July and October this year the
number of meals that we served here
increased by 50% food banks struggling
to meet increasing demand the numbers
keep going up and they show no signs of
abating the report predicts food prices
will still increase next year although
not as much except Bakery items
vegetables and meat which could jump up
between 5 and 7% some companies should
be having lower prices to attract
attention but I don't see it the reports
Project Lead says that might still
happen we're expecting the end of the
food inflation storm uh uh and perhaps
and that's really the the good news we
do believe that we could see some price
Wars here and there he predicts the
major grossers will soon offer more
incentives to lure Shoppers from other
big retailers and discount stores this
report also predicts energy costs and
inflation will likely be factors in food
pricing in 2024 along with climate
change and the effects of extreme
weather on crops around the world as
Canadians continue to try to manage
their household budgets which are
already tight Heidi pic Global News
Halifax and a little later Jeff simple
looks at the struggle indigenous
families face putting food on the table
and a call for a national strategy to
address food insecurity in Canada's
North but first a long awaited Federal
plan to cap emissions from Canada's oil
and gas industry is out it is a national
cap and trade system the government and
supporters say will be critical to meet
Canada's climate
targets oil and gas is the largest
emitted sector in Canada and unlike
almost every other sector of our economy
pollution from the oil and gas sector is
still going up a lot of details still
have to be negotiated but it's already
intensifying the fight between Ottawa
and the country's biggest oil producing
provinces especially Alberta over how to
reduce emissions as David Aken explains
Alberta's Premier is already vowing to
fight back well Donna the Trudeau
government says its cap and trade system
means it can both cut emissions and keep
Canada as one of the world's top oil
producers this Federal government's
focus on decarbonizing Canada's oil and
gas sector is both a plan to protect the
planet for future generations and to
enhance the short and long-term
competitiveness of the industry the plan
would see oil and gas emissions capped
at so many megatons per year each
industry player would be given credits
they'd use for every ton of emissions
released those that invest in
decarbonizing Technologies fastest would
not not need all their credits and could
sell any leftover to those moving slower
over time the cap gets smaller the
emission credits get more expensive and
that forces everyone in the industry to
cut this isn't going to work Alberta is
not going to accept in fact we're going
to fight it every step of the way from
Dubai where she's at the cop 28
conference Alberta's Premier said cap
and trade is ottawa's attempt to cut oil
production it's clearly a production cap
and that's what we've thought all along
is that been proposing this is why we've
been fighting against it so hard the
premier's wrong Randy baso is the only
albertan in Trudeau's cabinet this is
about a cap on pollution and Emissions
not a cap on production production
levels are predicted to go up but Smith
and Saskatchewan's Premier Scott Mo say
it is not needed that their oil and gas
Industries are already on a path to get
to Net Zero by 2050 they are are taking
a direct hit on our industry and they're
taking a direct hit on Alberta and it's
it's unacceptable I can tell you what
we're trying to do with the most
Innovative sector in this country which
is the oil and gas sector which is get
to the greenest barrel of oil on the
planet cu the greenest barrel of oil on
the planet is the one that the world's
going to want first and most there will
be lots of time and possibly an entire
federal election to Hash this all out it
was just a draft framework that was
released today draft regulations will
come out in 2024 finalized in 2025 with
the whole system coming online in 2026
done
okay David Aken in Ottawa thanks Canada
produces a lot of oil and production is
on the rise it's predicted to Jump by
10% next year and reach an all-time high
that's why some environmental groups say
the government's plan to cap emissions
won't act fast enough Eric senson looks
at how this cap and trade proposal has
landed in the oil patch from their
Calgary office Towers the response in
Canada's oil industry was Swift and
blunt ottawa's emissions Target is
effectively a cap on production
the Canadian Association of petroleum
producers says Ottawa risks curtailing
the energy Canadians rely on along with
jobs and government revenues the oil
sands Consortium pathway Alliance States
we still need a greater understanding of
how the cap integrates with other
policies to support our emission
reduction Investments the Calgary
Chamber of Commerce says it's an
economic blow for Alberta and the
country we need investor certainty and
right now this this cap as presented is
anything about providing uncertainty to
Industry across the board it is that
uncertainty around so many new policies
that worries the industry a carbon tax
carbon capture and storage proposed
methane regulations and now an emissions
cap and trade regime it's really
complicated we don't have draft
regulations yet and it's going to take
some time so companies may decide that
they don't want to invest waiting for
all those answers which effectively
would curtail production but others say
ottawa's emissions targets are largely
aligned with the industry's own
commitments I would really characterize
this emissions cap as a policy that is
designed to hold industry to account to
commitments that they have made for
emissions reductions and while
environmental groups believe Ottawa
could have gone further and faster they
are on balance pleased it's really great
to see this new cap policy emissions cap
policy uh take the next step towards
becoming reality and becoming
implemented to try and bend the curve on
this on the emission from this sector
some say it will all depend on how it
works can ottawa's technology fund be
set up to help the emitters ultimately
meet their targets investment in
technology projects is a must and you
have to make sure you invest the dollars
into the people with the emissions to
reduce those emissions it will take
years to see if the right balance is
struck to reduce emissions to meet
Canada's targets while maintaining an
industry that is a Lynch pin in the
Canadian economy Eric sens Global News
Toronto International students studying
in Canada will face new hurdles
Financial requirements for them will
double next year to keep up with the
cost of living immigration Minister Mark
Miller says those wanting to study in
Canada will need to prove they have over
$2,000 in their bank account on top of
the cost of tuition it would be a
mistake to blame International students
for the housing
crisis but it' also be a mistake to
invite them to come to Canada
with no support including how to put a
roof over their heads there are 900,000
foreign students in Canada on student
visas and there have been calls to limit
the number of future visas because many
post-secondary students both Canadian
and international are having trouble
finding and paying for housing two
months into Israel's war on Hamas there
is a somber mood in the country more
than 100 hostages taken in that attack
by Hamas on October 7th are still in
captivity and the country defense
minister predicts the fight in Gaza
could go on for two more
months there are Fierce battles across
Gaza now including in the South where
people had been told there would be safe
zones there are none the health
infrastructure is on his knees it's it's
almost collapsing that is what the
reality is it's almost collapsing tens
of thousands of people are streaming
into Rafa as far south as they can get
but there are reports of Israeli air
strikes there too gaza's Health Ministry
run by Hamas says the death toll has now
surpassed
17,000 Israel insists it is targeting
Hamas it claims Rockets were fired from
inside humanitarian zones showing
satellite imagery it says is proof the
IDF also raided a compound in jabalia
gaza's largest refugee camp overnight
saying it found a training center and
weapons
cach the American President Joe Biden
called Israel's prime minister again
today the White House says Biden
stressed the critical need to protect
civilians in Gaza and said that more
assistance is urgently needed a White
House spokesperson says discussions are
happening on trying to get another
humanitarian pause in fighting but there
is no deal one of Israel's Gates into
Gaza could reopen though and that offers
a tiny glimmer of hope Daniel Hamin is
in Jerusalem tonight
Danielle Donna negotiations are underway
to open a second Crossing into Gaza this
is the K Shalom Crossing in the South it
was prior to the war the main cargo
route into the Gaza Strip and according
to a un official negotiations are
promising and this of course would be a
huge boost to the humanitarian operation
on the ground if you ask the UN a chief
he'll say you can hardly even call it a
humanitarian operation anymore that's
how dire the situation is on the ground
now still on the topic of the United
Nations now on the Diplomatic front
tensions have reached a new high the
Israeli foreign minister today called
for the resignation of the UN Secretary
General Antonio gutterz saying that his
tenure as head of the world body was a
danger to World Peace some pretty strong
language there this is in reaction to a
rare move by gutterz he invoked article
99 of the UN Charter which formally uh
warns the security Council of a global
threat uh from Israel's war on Hamas
something that was backed by the EU
foreign Chief today uh not at all how
Israel sees it in fact the uh Israeli
foreign minister today on social media
said that calling for a ceasefire and
invoking article 99 constitute support
for
Hamas Donna all right Danielle hamam Jin
in Jerusalem tonight thank thank you
inflation in Canada's North coming up
how indigenous communities are bearing
the brunt of food
insecurity food insecurity not having
enough to eat is on the rise in Canada
stats Canada says about one in five
Canadian families reported experiencing
food insecurity last year among
indigenous families it's higher than
that now a pediatrician with a personal
connection to the north is raised in
concerns about the consequences of food
insecurity on indigenous children Jeff
simple has her
story Dr Anna bannery thought food
prices were high in her home City of
Toronto then she went grocery shopping
in the north $16 that's really expensive
record high inflation has sent food
prices soaring across the country but
nowhere more than Canada's northernmost
communities many inaccessible by Road
the pediatrician says indigenous
children are paying the heaviest price
indigenous children in these communities
uh do not have enough food to eat
bannery published a paper in the pla
Global Public Health Journal
highlighting the consequences of food
insecurity for indigenous youth the data
shows indigenous communities are twice
as likely to face shortages of food in
one Inuit community in Northern Quebec
the study found food and secure children
were around 2 cm shorter than other
Canadian kids it's not acceptable really
in a country as rich as Canada for
bannery the issue is personal she's
visited the Arctic more than 50 times
conducting research in pediatric clinics
then in 2004 bannery was asked if she
would adopt an Inuit baby he was just a
wonderful kid her son Nathan grew up in
Toronto they often visited his birth
mother and Foster family in their
Northern community of Clyde River but in
2018 at the age of 14
Nathan died by Suicide I'm still
struggling with it to Mark the fifth
anniversary of his death bannery
traveled to Clyde River last month where
Nathan's family is now struggling to
afford food
$1.97 in autoa Nathan's former Foster
mother points to a single can of soup on
sale for
$11.49 more than 10 times the price in
Toronto I know what it's like we've been
hungry but um yeah get
emotional she's a widow who shares a
home with three of her children and four
grandchildren yeah I don't know how
other families get to go through
that especially for the smaller
communities
and single
parents yeah it's really hard bannery is
calling for a national strategy to
address food insecurity in the north we
' got children who are starving this
country how is that reconciliation we
have to get beyond the rhetoric and and
make some real substantial changes Jeff
simple Global News
Toronto the Assembly of First Nations
has a new National Chief Cindy Woodhouse
was elected after six rounds of voting
to Canada and to Canadians we need your
support you have to work with first
nation's people in a good way if if you
don't listen to our people and you don't
listen to our Chiefs you don't answer
them then there's problems
and so to Canada we're we're we're
coming for you woodh house is from
Manitoba where she was the afn regional
Chief she played a key role in the $23
billion child welfare settlement and
she's promised to bring stability to the
afn which is the largest indigenous
advocacy organization in
Canada still ahead does the punishment
fit the crime for this burrito bow
[Music]
thrower we all lose our cool from time
to time but some people take it to the
next level a woman in Ohio who hurled a
burrito bowl at a Chipotle worker will
soon learn what it's like to be on the
other side of the
[Music]
counter that episode got 39-year-old
rosemary Hayne convicted of assault she
agreed to a reduce sentence of 30 days
in jail if she works 20 hours a week for
two months at a fast food restaurant and
it does not have to be a Chipotle how do
you spell justice well we all mess up
our words sometimes too and now the most
mispronounced words of 2023 are out
compiled by the online language learning
company Babel siza she's one of
spotify's top 10 most dreamed artists of
2023 that's siza most people have
trouble with Killian Murphy he's the
actor who starred in Christopher Nolan's
Oppenheimer and there's samile try using
that one in a s sentence it's the
winning word on this year's scripts
National Spelling be and can you say
shoet of course you can it's the name of
fashion designer Carl logger's
cat next a global news reporter opens up
about her viral clapback to a viewer's
vicious
[Music]
email having a job on TV puts you in the
public eye and those of us who do it get
all kinds of feedback from viewers the
hair the clothes the way we speak all of
it is scrutinized especially if you're a
woman and the comments well they can
range from good bad to downright ugly
lesie Horton from Global Calgary knows
all about that I just going to respond
to an email that I just got uh saying
congratulations on your pregnancy if
you're going to wear old bus driver
pants you have to expect emails like
this so thanks for that um no I'm not
pregnant I actually lost my uist cancer
last year and um this is what women of
my age look like so if it is offensive
to you that is
unfortunate think about the emails that
you
sent and Leslie Horton is with me now
lesle I know you've worked at Global
Calgary for I think 26 years you
probably heard a lot of things for
viewers from viewers over the years what
made you take on this one well I had
heard from this man uh for the past few
years Donna I he was not a stranger to
me in the viewer email nasty Department
uh but when this one came in it just uh
hit a little bit differently I had a bit
of a viseral reaction but I read it I I
put it aside I went on to do my traffic
hit I was getting ready to go and these
words just came out of my mouth they
came out on a cellular level I didn't
know I was going to respond I didn't
plan on the words I was using to respond
they just came out and afterwards I
thought well apparently I hit my line of
saying you may not speak to me that way
yeah it sounds like you just really
couldn't take it anymore I know the clip
has gone viral what are you hearing from
people a 99 % of the comments are very
positive Donna I I'm hearing from people
that say you look like that you
shouldn't be on TV you look like you
weigh 200 pound and when's that baby
popping out it's not no uterus but I
have heard a majority of people saying
uh thank you for speaking out thank you
for uh putting that conversation out
there so that we can have really maybe a
discussion about how we're treating each
other and a discussion about lashing out
at other folks and what's your intention
when you're sending those emails the
intention of this one was to shame hurt
humiliate and embarrass me but I get to
choose how I feel so when I put that
line up I didn't feel any of those
things I just felt like no you may not I
hope you're feeling supported lesli you
know I think the world is actually full
of kind people what's your take away
from this the world is full of kind
people there's a lot of kind people out
there there's a the world also has some
folks who really just want to hurt and
to lash out and perhaps it makes them
feel elevated it takes the conversation
nowhere uh it there's it's nonsense
there's no need for it if you feel like
you need to hurt somebody and lash out
at a at a a a Calgary mom on TV then
maybe have a Snickers take a look at
yourself and just calm down go outside
pet a dog lesie Horton in Calgary thank
you for taking time with us thanks Donna
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna freezen Hanukkah the
Jewish Festival of light begins its
sundown tonight this year in the shadow
of war the celebrations are muted in
some places they've even been
canceled in Israel families and
supporters of the 138 people still being
held hostage in Gaza gathered for a
candle lighting ceremony Hanukkah is
meant to celebrate the Triumph of
lightness over darkness and is usually a
joyous time not so much this year thanks
for watching nthu Garo will be at the
anchor tomorrow and I will see you again
next week
[Music]
bye-bye